listen what's the uh first thing you're
gonna do if you make a world champion
first thing i
i'm gonna have to go and buy some
turtles
yeah well i said to the kids when i was
leaving the house this morning i was
gonna bring back the title and they
thought i said turtle
so yeah so naturally i i don't want to
let them down but if i could bring home
the thailand turtle they sure would be
thicker
if you married my daughter would you
support her in the way that she deserves
to be supported
yes would you be honest and faithful to
her
yes
will you devote yourself entirely to her
for the rest of your life
of course
gaylord [ __ ]
will you be my son-in-law
hey
dad
you want to have a catch
i'd like that
i'm gonna be a grandfather you happy
about that absolutely delighted this is
a disaster no this is not a disaster it
is an earthquake is a disaster
your grandmother having alzheimer's so
bad she doesn't even know who the [ __ ] i
am that's a disaster this is a good
thing this is a blessing
i got it i got it
hi daddy
what's the matter honey you don't feel
so good
you feel like you want to throw up okay
gil oh my god
taylor
why are you just standing there
waiting for our head to spin around
but we're a family of late bloomers i
didn't until i was 14 nor did olive what
does that matter i'm adopted
what
oh my god who told you
guys we were gonna do this at the right
time
listen to me
sometimes even when a man and a woman
love each other very much like your
mother and i used to their insides just
don't cooperate with each other
don't ever let somebody tell you
you can't do something
not even me
all right
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can't do it
you want something go get it
period
oh jim you're here
uh i was just uh walking by your uh your
room and uh and you you know i was
thinking uh boy it's been a long time
since we've had the little father-son uh
uh chat
oh i i almost forgot i uh i uh i bought
some magazines
do you want to just flip to the center
section
well this is the this is the uh female
form and uh they have focused on the
breasts uh which are used primarily to
feed
young infants
when i was five
so this fairy comes into my room
and i'm like yeah right you're a fairy
she pulls out this invisible cloak she
ties it around my neck
and she tells me that it's impenetrable
you know what a pencil means
it means that nothing go through it
no bullets
nothing and when she told me that i was
supposed to give it to my daughter on
her fifth birthday and i forgot
can i touch it
sugar
i don't feel it yeah it's pretty cool
huh
if you want i could take it off and tie
around your shoulder she told me how to
do it
unless you think it's stupid
don't you need it
i don't know anymore
so what do you think you wanted
you